on est bien peu de choses et mon ami la
rose me l'a dit ce
matin à l'aurore je suis né btisé de
rosé je me suis
épanouie
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre 7e
épisode du petit IR dans l'épisode
précédent nous étions au centre de la
ressource où Marik avait annoncé ses
premiers choix pour la composition de la
troupe finale Adeline Emy Thomas et
Zidane étaient ravis de prendre part au
projet cette semaine nous retournons à
l'IME de la montagne où la muse en scène
va pouvoir annoncer ses nouveaux choix
et poursuivre les entretiens individuels
elle est en compagnie de Maë un jeune
musicothérapeute embarqué est dans
l'aventure bonjour à tous alors
aujourd'hui on est à l'IME de la
montagne et je vous présente donc Maël
qui donc remplace Hélène il va se
présenter et voilà donc comme l'a dit
Marik je m'appelle Maël je suis
musicothérapeute et je remplace Hélène à
l'EM de la montagne donc pour quelques
mois et donc je reprends en main le
projet du petit émir avec
Marik
alors pourquoi je vous ai réuni
aujourd'hui
ah ben c'est pour vous dire que vous
êtes tous pris au projet le petit émir
ouais bravo bravo à
tous alors toi David c'est pour le rôle
aussi du des villageois et celui qui
prend la parole Mathias bien sûr c'est
pour le le rôle du narrateur ça va tu es
content ouais c'est un gros texte
j'espère que ça va aller au niveau du
texte qu'est-ce que tu en
penses le texte moi personnellement
j'aime bien d'accord ok alors vous
pouvez me montrer ce que vous avez
travaillé avec Maë ce matin c'est
l'occasion pour tous de montrer leur
joie de jouer ensemble Nicolas tu te
souviens
maintenant on va se voir en individuel
donc on va avec Maë va venir avec moi et
on va vous tester au niveau des des
instruments ou du texte par rapport à au
au projet petit émir oui voici
maintenant l'heure des bilan individuels
et c'est David qui débute d'accord oui
vas-y assie-toi bon alors tu es content
oui tu vas faire partie du du spectacle
oui et et j'aime bien ce que je fais là
aujourd'hui est-ce qu'est-ce que tu vas
faire tu sais c'est quoi le rôle tu t'en
rappelles euh oui je sais c'est le le
rôle je dois je dois jouer le
le personnage ouais quel personnage tu
joues le rôle d'un des villageois oui
qui dit au au narrateurs qu'il y a plus
d'enfants ici d'accord donc vas-y est-ce
que tu te rappelles au moins de une de
tes répliques et tu peux me la dire avec
du ton de façon
théâtrale vous perdez votre temps ok une
autre fois sans le texte vas-y façon
théâtrale ouvre les bras un peu vous
votre
temps voilà bon David on aimerait bien
entendre ce que tu fais sur lerboua oui
donc est-ce que tu peux nous montrer un
petit peu
oui
ok super super génial donc c'est bon tu
es partant alors pour l'aventure oui oui
bon ben c'est parti c'est à présent au
tour de Samuel de se présenter face à
Marik et Maë voilà donc Samuel tu es
nouveau dans dans ce projet hein tu es
content de participer à aux percussions
et au spectacle euh ouais je alors pour
te présenter un peu Samuel tu as quel
âge euh moi j'ai 20 ans 20 ans d'accord
et tu joues de la percussion
oui tout le temps tout le
temps fois FO une fois par semaine avec
Maë d'accord ok donc là tu vas jouer le
rôle des villageois ah oui ça te dit
c'est oui ouis donc est-ce que tu veux
bien nous nous montrer ce que tu sais
faire sur sur une der Boua Bou ou ou
donc tu fais un rythme simple pas besoin
faire compliquer non non
ok
bravo merci Samuel donc ce que disait
Marik c'est qu'on on va travailler
pendant 4 mois pour préparer ce
spectacle c'est ça donc toi tu es tu es
prêt à travailler et à t'amuser pour
arriver à un résultat quand même bien
ouais ouais ok
superz merci
beaucoup à Nicolas maintenant de montrer
ses
compétences bienvenue Nicolas ça va
oui tu fais partie des villageois de
ceux qui jouent est-ce que tu es content
de faire partie de ce projet alors
beaucoup ok alors c'est le l'idée des
villageois ça a un peu de toi aussi
parce que tu es quelqu'un qui joue très
très bien à la derboua et c'était voilà
un réel désir de t'avoir dans la troupe
en tout cas oui alors tu vas nous
montrer ça oui on aimerait bien que tu
nous montres un petit peu ce que tu ce
que tu sais faire sur la
derboua
super yeah bravo merci dans le dans la
la pièce de théâtre c'est toi qui sera
le leader au niveau des des instruments
d'accord donc il faut que tu apprennes à
lancer mais aussi à arrêter et ça avec
ma vous allez travailler là-dessus parce
que si tu joues joues en solo comme ça
au bout d'un moment on entendra plus
d'accord on va travailler ça dans les
prochains mois et ça va être super en
tout cas on est ravi que tu fasses
partie du
projet puis Mathias se présente pour
montrer ses talents d'acteur donc déjà
quelle impression ça te fait tes
ressentis j'en suis
r est-ce que tu as déjà travaillé le
texte oui d'accord est-ce que tu peux me
faire le début de la pièce par exemple
j'ai dit au milieu de N part
oui ne crever qu' pour démolition
partiel de mon appareil àou mon
44 j'ai dit merde nu de mon moteur est
cramé j'ai dit bouge-toi le nez ça c'est
le premier jour ok c'est bon ok donc
c'est bien mais il faut quand même faire
des efforts tu le sais de
quoi à quoi il faut faire uneulation
voilà tu es partant pour l'aventure avec
Maë et toute l'équipe là oui moi je suis
par ok ben c'est super en commence on
commence à travailler dès la semaine
prochaine alors qu'arrive le tour de
Marco c'est le coup de théâtre Maë
apprend que Marco est déjà engagé dans
un cours de judo et que les horaires
sont incompatibles avec les répétitions
mais elle décide de voir si une solution
est possible donc j'ai eu Sophie au
téléphone qui m'a expliqué que tu été
licencié au judo et que et du coup tu tu
faisais le judo le mercredi après-midi
en même temps que la préparation du
spectacle le petit IR donc c'est pas
possible de faire les deux en même temps
il va falloir que tu choisisses donc
soit tu fais le spectacle et les percu
avec avec Marika et moi soit tu choisis
le judo mais tu peux pas faire les deux
en même temps donc je vais je vais
appeler tes parents pour savoir ce
qu'ils en pens parce que ils ont déjà
pris la licence et cetera mais c'est
vraiment à toi de choisir tuas tu as un
petit peu de temps pour choisir tu tu
peux tu peux tu peux attendre quelques
jours avant de nous donner ta réponse
mais tu peux pas faire les deux en même
temps est-ce que tu comprends bien oui
alors dis-moi est-ce que est-ce que pour
le moment dans l'idée est-ce que tu
préfères faire percu spectacle ou est-ce
que tu préfères le judo le spectacle le
spectacle ouais voilà Marik m'a expliqué
que en percu tu étais doué et que ça
serait vraiment un plus de t'avoir dans
l'équipe est-ce que vous les gars est-ce
que vous voulez avoir Marco dans
l'équipe ouiou ouais Marco tu ve tu veux
être tu veux être parmi nous alors ok
super bon ben parfait ben je te on va se
voir après tout à l'heure là tu viens
nous voir hein pour tester au niveau des
percussions avec Maë parce qu'il t'a
jamais entendu je crois non et j'ai
vraiment envie d'entendre ça d'accord ok
tu viens nous montrer c'est maintenant à
Marco de faire son choix Marco tu es
content de faire partie du spectacle
alors parce que là on vient te reprendre
au judo donc tu as compris ce que Maë
t'a expliqué oui tu es partant alors
pour faire les percussions avec nous
jouer du d'aderboua ou de du jumb voilà
donc ça sera ça ton rôle hein donc
rentrer sur scène avec un jumb tu peux
nous montrer comment tu
joues vas-y tu peux prendre
l'instrument ouais super ok
bravo merci Marco tu es partant alors
pour le rôle des musiciens sur scène ok
ben merci beaucoup
Marco bon ben c'était super ouais
c'était cool on a eu des beaux moments
ouais on on a on a tous les jeunes qu'on
voulait là je pense que y il y a du
potentiel on va pouvoir préparer un
spectacle intéressant ouais je pense
qu'en percussion effectivement tu vas
pouvoir travailler avec eux surtout avec
Nicolas les
entrées la fin là c'est c'est c'est un
honneur au niveau au niveau percus
là-dessus il y a pas de souci ouais
ouais bon après Mathias bon il nous a
confirmé queil y avait pas de souci au
niveau du texte et de la présence donc
c'est chouette il est volontaire ouais
ouais ouais ouais et ensuite bah tous
nos bah David je fait juste dire une
phrase et il se l' mis donc c'est
chouette ouais ouais ouais tout à fait
ouais bon ben très bien donc toi
qu'est-ce que tu en penses du projet
est-ce que tu es partant B bien entendu
je suis partant c'est je suis vraiment
étonné de de de des capacités de ces
jeunes qui qui
vraiment au niveau percussion ils
tiennent le rythme ils ont une pulsation
vraiment régulière ils ont ils sont
beaucoup dans le regard dans
l'interaction et cetera donc je pense
que voilà je suis vraiment je suis
vraiment enthousiaste vis-à-vis de ce
spectacle qu'on va qu'on va préparer
dans les prochains mois et je voilà je
suis persuadé qu'on va faire un il y
aura un super résultat
et voilà la troupe est maintenant plus
nombreuse et les sourires sont au
rendez-vous lors de la prochaine
émission vous découvrirez la troupe
réunie au grand complet avec les tout
derniers comédiens qui arriveront en
surprise Marik leur exposera
l'intégralité du projet sur leur
futurieeux de répétition à très
bientôt y